the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
[Music]
tonight on politics now churches win in
court
the new coveted regulations for places
of worship after a federal court
sides with them plus i will not
give this false narrative about my state
any more attention than it is already
unfortunately received
nevada's election continues to be
defended by
democrats and attacked by republicans
the latest congressional hearing on
election security
and we agreed we will not leave town
until we've made law
will we have a deal or won't we the
latest discussion in a constantly
changing debate over a covid relief bill
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
churches can now have up to 25 percent
capacity after
a court ruling thanks for watching
politics now i'm vanessa murphy
the change came after a federal court
ruling this week
they had been capped at 50 people total
but a church in lyon county sued saying
that was
unconstitutional and a judge agreed orco
mana shows us
that while the court ruling is welcomed
news for some congregations
many tell us they'll still be playing it
safe
we have lost a lot of people to this um
to this to to covet kelsey west is the
senior pastor at nehemiah ministries
his church has the proper social
distancing and sanitation measures in
place but because coronavirus has
directly impacted his congregation
he'll continue to only do virtual
services we're still
able to do the work of the lord and i
don't have to
physically put people in harm's way this
comes even as churches in nevada now
have new covet 19 regulations
a federal court overturned an order
tuesday that upheld limited gathering
saying houses of worship can have 25
percent of their capacity
instead of the 50-person limit put in
place by governor steve sizulak
cantor jessica hutchings with
congregation near tamid says they're
also fully online they even stopped
parking lot services when the statewide
pause was announced last month
we have a committee of doctors and of
board members that make decisions based
on what our government is advising
and what is safe for our community so we
will be meeting to discuss
how and if this changes anything that
we're doing right now church goers we
spoke to say they'll continue to stay
home
i'm afraid of what would happen
i think it's better to do it virtually
but i just want to be on the safe side
so right now i don't go to church
basically while some look forward to
in-person services during the holidays
pastor west has one simple message
this season i just want people to be
safe that's my prayer orca mana
8 news now
and again that was orco mana reporting
governor sisilak said in a statement he
was
disappointed by the court's decision but
will
follow it he's still urging churches who
choose to hold
in-person services to be safe by
requiring masks and
enforcing social distancing
and a new eviction moratorium was also
announced this week
it is similar to the cdc version that
expires at the end of the month
joe moeller tells us that tenants must
print out a declaration
and make sure their landlord receives it
i have a two-year-old and a
nine-year-old and i'm 32 weeks pregnant
stephanie edwards is in the process of
going to court over an eviction
the mediator gave us talk to her and
talked to us
and they gave us time next month on the
fifth to be out she hopes the new
moratorium will help her stay in her
home
the only place we can really go is if we
do get evicted is california back to my
parents house
sunday the governor announced a new
moratorium that will last through march
31st
tenants must take action the tenants do
need to
sign a declaration saying that they are
eligible for protection under the
directive this is what the declaration
looks like
it needs to be printed and given to the
landlord morgenshaw from nevada legal
services says if you make less than 99
000 a year cannot pay rent due to a
covert related issue and or at risk of
homelessness
you are protected there is no point
up to lockout that is too late so
even if you end up going to court
you can bring the declaration with you
to court you should not wait for a
notice to take action and always keep a
copy and proof you set the document
make sure that you're still applying for
rent assistance if possible
uh because this directive does not
forgive rent that's due
it doesn't stop rent stop the late fees
from accruing
joe muller 8 news now
we do have a link to that declaration
on our website at eight newsnow dot com
president donald trump continued to
criticize nevada's election this week
including claiming on twitter that
thousands of non-citizens voted in
nevada
last week the nevada supreme court
unanimously said the trump campaign
failed to show any serious errors or
flaws in the
election our electors voted for
president-elect
biden on monday of this week
following weeks of election fraud
accusations stemming from the
president's supporters
the senate homeland security committee
held a hearing to
examine those accusations raquel martin
from our washington
d.c bureau tells us more about what
happened
president-elect joe biden even as more
republicans acknowledged joe biden as
the next president wisconsin republican
senator ron johnson
says he's not ready to sweep this
election under the rug fraudulent voting
did occur
at a senate homeland security hearing
wednesday johnson insisted
human and voting machine errors led to
miscounts
many of these irregularities raised
concerns
and they do need to be taken seriously
attorneys leading the president's
re-election fight in nevada
and wisconsin back johnson's claim 2
000 of those ballots in dane and
milwaukee county
had no initials at all but michigan
democratic senator gary peters says
the debate is over statements that have
been made
have all been rejected by courts of law
peter slammed johnson for advancing what
he calls
dangerous misinformation gives a
platform to
conspiracy theories and lies and it's a
destructive exercise that has no place
in the united states senate kris krebs
the nation's former top election
security official
again denied that voting machines were
compromised
i think we're past the point where we
need to be having conversations about
the outcome of this election but
missouri republican senator josh hawley
disagrees
president trump has every right to
continue to raise these serious serious
issues
and hawley still hasn't ruled out
objecting to the election results
when they're presented to congress on
january 6. raising concerns about the
election is a totally legitimate thing
i'm studying
how one might do that what the procedure
is and
trying to gather evidence in washington
raquel martin
nevada senator jackie rosen is also on
that committee
and said our election was fair and
secure
both our republican secretary of state
and our democratic attorney general have
stated there is no evidence
of widespread voter fraud occurred in
nevada and our highest court has said
the same and i will not
give this false narrative about my state
any more attention than it has already
unfortunately received
the i team has looked into allegations
of fraud and found
two cases of a deceased voter having a
ballot cast
in their name in all five people voted
twice
all of the allegations have been
forwarded to the secretary
of state's office the clark county
school district and the largest
teachers union have reached a tentative
agreement on reopening schools
the plan allows for the possibility of
some students and staff returning to the
classroom
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us what to expect
if the plan is approved by the board of
trustees
the plan right now focuses on the
district's youngest students so
those who are in elementary school ccsd
says pre-k through third grade students
may
possibly return first for face-to-face
instruction
next year our babies need to be in
school
they're the ones that need the social
interaction a big step in bringing
students back to schools for in-person
learning
the district and clark county education
association came to a tentative
agreement
following months of negotiations the
plan outlines certain standards and
safety precautions
that includes mandatory covid19 testing
for educators
and providing personal protective
equipment ccea's executive director
calls reopening schools a trial and
error process but
this allows for an incremental approach
being
ready with a plan is absolutely critical
and we think this is a plan that allows
flexibility
allows us to address immersion issues
that suggest
maybe we expand maybe we contract the
district will not require students to
take a covet 19 test before coming back
on campus
as for the vaccine the district plans to
work with the southern nevada health
district to make it a voluntary option
for educators
the tentative agreement will be
presented at the board meeting january
14th
trustees will also consider a potential
reopening plan on that date
until then all staff working remotely
will continue to do so
reporting in las vegas kristin drummond
8 news now
well since the plan includes mandatory
ppe
and screening how will an already
underfunded school district
pay for it the plan relies on federal
government help
we absolutely have to have the money in
place for the safety component because
that was one of our top priorities
not only for the safety of our staff but
for our students so making sure that
that adult
feels as safe as possible and that the
students are safe so without that we
would have to go back to the table
employees who can work remotely will
continue to do so until january 15th to
comply with the governor's stay-at-home
2.0
order it was report card night so to
speak
for clark county school superintendent
dr jesus jarrah
he had his review during this week's
board meeting
overall board members say there's room
for improvement but
they're ready to do it together
the superintendent uh you're you're
still our leader
we need you let's work together and
get take care of these kids and all of
our staff and our community
i want you to know that i am confident
that
you and this new board will work
together with dr aldry
you guys will um rewrite some of the
policies
to be grouped a little bit better
together and
that um in six months to a year
that things will be in a much better
place
superintendent jara responded saying in
part i will continue to communicate
transparently and directly on all
matters affecting our students and
schools
this will be even more critical as
safely reopening
our schools soon becomes a reality you
can read the full statement
at eight newsnow dot com
covid relief is still in the works
when you compromise obviously you know
not everyone's going to be 100 percent
happy with the product but
ultimately that's what gets the job done
up next congresswoman susie lee talks
about compromise efforts in her caucus
plus i'm alexandra limon in washington
lawmakers on capitol hill say they're
close to reaching a deal
on a coronavirus relief package but one
democratic senator
said
round team we have the games
welcome back to politics now
lawmakers say they're on the brink of
reaching a deal for another
round of covid relief the latest version
of a coronavirus relief package proposes
leaving out both money for state and
local governments and covet related
lawsuit protections for business
but congress has said they will work
through the weekend
to try and get it done nevada democratic
congresswoman suzy lee has been a part
of a bipartisan
group trying to hammer out that deal my
i-team colleague david charns
interviewed her about the bill
and he started by asking about another
potential
one-time stimulus payment for everyone
the six hundred dollars enough and is it
something that you would support and you
would you support more
the uh stimulus package i think has been
an
important part that got added in because
mitch mcconnell refuses
to include state and local funding in
this package
and so uh basically there's a hundred
and forty billion dollars that will go
in
uh to these stimulus uh this these
stimulus checks
i don't think this package is enough at
all i mean
first of all remember you know our own
federal reserve chairman back in may
said that we needed to go big um and we
started out with the three trillion
dollar package it went to two trillion
and now we're less than a trillion
i believe we will come back to the uh we
will come back with another package in
the next congress
uh and so i think this is obviously a
stop gap measure
it's something to get relief to people
who especially
in southern nevada so many of our
families have been struggling uh
and businesses are on the verge of
collapse and so
this couldn't come at a more critical
time on top of getting that stimulus out
we're also once again talking about
funding the government
um you know no one wants a government
shutdown
um why you know why are we
continuously having these these debates
in in washington um you know and it
always seems to happen
right in the middle of you know
christmas time beginning of the new year
when people
you know want to know that they're going
to have a job you know so why
you know why is this happening yet again
and how can we prevent it from
from continuing to happen you know david
i um when i first came to congress i was
really struck
you know i i ran on basically a
commitment
to try to be bipartisan to work with
my republican colleagues and i must say
from the
minute i stepped foot here it really
struck me at
how much effort goes into keeping us
apart and so i think that
the fact that we get to this
breakmanship especially when it comes to
funding
our government is really uh the illness
and
um and so i think it's something that
we're going to have to continue
to work on and i must say that i'm proud
of the effort
that we made with the problem solvers
caucus to keep pushing
and really we were ranking rank and file
members who came to the table
to continue to push for this package and
you know i'm hopeful under this
under president-elect biden that this
type of brinkmanship
in this ultra divisiveness is going to
change and we're going to see
a new period of trying to cooperate and
compromise and work together
now when you compromise obviously you
know
not everyone's going to be 100 percent
happy with the product but
ultimately that's what gets the job done
we put that entire interview on
eightnewsnow.com
our washington dc bureau correspondent
alexandra limon has stayed on top of
these relief package negotiations
i asked her about what we can all expect
now
lawmakers say they are once again on the
brink of a kovic 19 relief
deal our washington correspondent
alexandra lamone has more on that
alex why has this process been so drawn
out
you know there were a few different
issues that were holding up the
negotiations but one of the biggest
things
was the unemployment benefits we know
that democrats have been pushing for a
long time to both
extend and increase the amount of
federal unemployment benefits
that people get but for a long time
republicans were really trying to push
back on that in fact some republicans
didn't want any
additional unemployment benefits at all
but in the end they did
agree to some extension you know it was
for a shorter time
than democrats wanted and also for less
money and instead at the very last
minute what they said
instead of doing these longer and larger
unemployment benefits
what they wanted to do republicans was
send out another round of those one-time
stimulus checks to americans this came
up at the very last minute
because for you know weeks now these
negotiations have been going on and they
didn't include stimulus checks
and that caught some democrats off guard
in fact uh
senator mark warner virginia said you
know he was pretty upset about it he
said it didn't make sense
money to americans who are employed
rather than sending more money to people
who lost their jobs who may be on the
brink of losing their homes
and who maybe don't even have you know
the money to feed their families and so
that was one of the issues that really
held
up negotiations at the very end and
that's in addition to the things that
have been
ongoing like whether or not to provide
more money to stay in local governments
where do you expect this will go now so
lawmakers are now saying they do
expect to be able to reach a deal
by this weekend initially the deadline
was friday
but now they're talking about extending
the budget you know for
one or two days worth of funding um so
that they can hold that larger budget
deal
and tie the stimulus package to it and
pass it then so it is
possible that we could see that happen
this weekend despite these last minute
disagreements they say they are still
hopeful that can happen
that was alexandra lamone from our
washington d.c bureau
from the revival of the film tax credit
to
public records laws and what kids learn
in school
we'll take you through some of the bills
being written for our 2021 legislative
the valley's news leader
the 2021 legislative session begins in
february and we are approaching
900 bill draft requests already
on a wide variety of subjects nearly 200
of them have been written
so this week we want to highlight some
of those in the assembly
assembly bill 10 would double the
criminal penalties for vehicular
manslaughter
right now it's a maximum of six months
and a thousand dollar fine
it would go up to 364 days and a two
thousand dollar fine
it is sponsored by the judiciary
committee assembly bill 20 would revive
the film tax credit for companies that
shoot movies in nevada
the film tax credit was initially the
baby of now attorney general aaron ford
when
he was the senate majority leader in
2013.
it was initially 80 million dollars in
transferable credits
the legislature gutted it to 10 million
dollars a year later and gave the rest
to tesla during a special session
it was brought back again in 2017 but
became part of the
education budget deal in 2019.
the latest version is sponsored by the
committee on revenue
ab39 would hide more records from the
public
it would make notes and working papers
that are deemed for personal use not
applicable to public records requests
that is from the committee on government
affairs
ab56 would require high school students
to take
a class on the holocaust or the history
of genocides
this one is from the education committee
and assembly bill 60 targets
non-disclosure agreements
it voids any part of a contract or
agreement that requires someone to
not testify in court about criminal
conduct or sexual harassment
that one is from the judiciary committee
the 2021 legislature starts on february
1st in carson city
they have not yet said what said what
kind of covid precautions will be
in place
your first month's payment and zero do
it signing
here's what we're keeping an eye on next
week in what to watch
on monday clark county is holding a
virtual town hall on the eviction
moratorium and rental assistance
it's meant to help both those facing
eviction and landlords who are not
receiving
their normal rent thanks for watching
politics now
[Music]
you